Michael Myers.
You can shoot him 6 times, you can even make
6 terrible sequels.
But Michael Myers will never die.
Halloween is back.
Intro.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
Today we’re taking a look at the trailer
for Halloween.
I’m gonna be breaking it down shot by shot
for you and pulling out all those juicy Things
You Missed.
Now when you watch the trailer you’ll notice
something very early on.
Check out this clip.
“We’re here to investigate a patient who
killed three innocent teenagers on Halloween
in 1978.”
Anyone who’s seen the movies knows he’s
killed a bit more than three people.
I mean probably only our boy Dead Meat knows
the actual number, but what’s going on right
here?
What’s the deal with that?
Well, it was previously believed that this
movie takes place in a fourth or depending
on your view, possibly fifth alternate universe,
and that it would branch off from the main
timeline after Halloween 2.
However this trailer claims that after being
shot by Dr. Loomis in the original movie,
Michael was captured and taken into captivity,
where he spent the last 40 years.
That means this takes place in a timeline
where none of these movies happened.
So this is essentially a fresh slate for the
franchise.
That’s not to say it doesn’t have some
homages to those other films hidden in the
trailer though, so make sure you watch this
whole video to see all of those.
Unfortunately for us, that new timeline means
we may have to sit through yet another scene
of the characters finding out that Michael
Myers is invincible, as we have painstakingly
had to do in pretty much every movie.
That’s essentially confirmed when we see
the older Laurie Strode doing target practice
in her backyard.
And trying to stab him with a knife.
Come on Laurie!
You know better than this!
Notice the guy at the beginning says that
Michael killed three innocent teenagers (I
mean are there really such thing as innocent
teenagers though?), but he makes no mention
of Michael M killing his sister at the age
of 6, which is what happens in the first scene
of the original 1978 Halloween.
In this movie, Laurie has a granddaughter,
and she has a line that confirms that Michael
is not even related to her.
“No.
He is not her brother, that is something that
people made up.”
So that might lead some people to believe
that the opening scene didn’t happen in
this timeline, but I think they’ve just
neglected to mention the murder of Michael’s
older sister Judith, because we do still he
a sketch of Dr. Loomis in the police report,
and it’s mentioned that Michael was shot
by his own psychiatrist.
I can’t imagine why he’d have a psychiatrist
without those events taking place in 1963
first.
It’s also really the only explanation as
to why do these kids in 2018, 40 years after
the fact, know about a murderer who only killed
three people all those years ago.
And to the point that he’s a household name.
And one more thing on the whole idea of Laurie
and Michael not actually being siblings.
My theory is that they’re taking the Halloween
3 approach, to where it takes place in a different
universe entirely, but the other movies still
exist as fictional movies in this universe.
So in this universe, someone made a “based
on a true story” movie or book about the
killer Michael Myers, and then sequels started
to come out that were not so based on a true
story.
That’s where the idea that Laurie and Michael
are siblings may have originated.
Of course, it’s also possible that they
really are related and Laurie just doesn’t
know it, much like in Rob Zombie’s Halloween
II.
Here we get to see the police reports from
that Halloween night all those years ago,
and they do contain some nuggets I thought
you might be interested in.
This is Laurie’s injury report, detailing
the slash across right neck and shoulder and
bruising and contusions around neck.
This is only on screen for less than 1/10th
of a second, but there’s a photograph of
someone’s hand, and this almost looks like
a reflection of the mask, but I might just
be reading too much into it.
Here we’ve got the large knife, evidence
from the upstairs bedroom, which of course
was labeled with the date 10/31/78.
Then again, only a tenth of a second, they
show off evidence photos of the mask in what
seems to be a tiled room of some kind.
This photo was probably taken after the fact
because it looks like nobody’s wearing the
mask and the background here is some kind
of tiled area; whereas at the end of Halloween,
Michael ends up in the grass outside the house.
This is most likely a photo of Tommy Doyle,
the boy that Laurie was babysitting on that
fateful night.
But behind that we get a little glimpse of
the police report text.
The only interesting thing I pulled from that
is the mention of this “Deputy Miller”,
who as far as I know, isn’t an existing
character in this franchise, so this may be
someone new who is retconned into the story.
Other than that, it just seems to be a recount
of the events of the OG Halloween.
Another question.
Who are these people investigating Michael
Myers, and why now?
Why are they trying to get a rise of out of
him by showing the mask?
OK, I guess that’s more than one question.
But I think this guy could be disciple of
Dr. Loomis, or in any event, the successor
to Dr. Loomis who goes into town and warns
people about how dangerous Michael is, just
as Loomis did in the films that he was in.
Unlike his predecessor however, he doesn’t
seem to have given up on his patient just
yet.
Laurie asks him if he believes in the boogeyman,
and he says no, suggesting he might not see
Michael as a monster like Laurie does.
The woman that he’s working with is documenting
everything using the audio recorder, and her
name tag also gives us a couple clues.
First, we see the name of the facility Smith’s
Grove State Hospital.
The original facility that Michael broke out
of in Halloween was called Smith’s Grove
Sanitarium, so it’s likely the same place
that just got a name at some point along the
line.
You have to believe if he can break out once
he can do it again.
The chick’s name is Dana Haines.
There is a security guard named Haines at
a different hospital known as Grace Anderson
Sanitarium in Halloween: Resurrection, but
I doubt that’s even a reference seeing as
how hated that movie is, it’s just my job
to point it out to you though.
Wait, hold up, hold up.
OK.
This kid’s a ninja.
This kid’s a skeleton.
What’s this kid supposed to be, Busta Rhymes?
But on a more serious note, this scene is
a major throwback to the original Halloween
where Laurie walks home from school with her
two friends, but this time it’s Laurie’s
granddaughter.
They just put this Boba Tea in the shot so
you can tell that this is the 2018 one.
Laurie is absolutely crazy in this movie,
she’s basically spent the last 40 years
preparing for Michael, and if you read between
the lines you can see everyone’s subtle
condescending behaviour towards her.
Even her own family treats her like a nutcase.
“Mom?
What bus crashed?”
Additionally the neighborhood kids seem to
have no respect for her authority.
She’s basically turned her house into a
fortress with cameras, sirens, even a secret
bunker.
It looks like they’re setting up a classic
old lady who cried wolf scenario.
Laurie’s been freaking out for the last
40 years over the return of Michael Myers…
no, not that Return of Michael Myers… and
basically when he does really come back, nobody’s
gonna take her seriously.
Cause she’s the crazy lady.
This bathroom scene may be a reference to
the opening scene of H20, where a woman is
attacked by Michael in a rest stop bathroom.
In this case it’s a gas station bathroom,
and it looks like a mechanic also faces the
wrath of Michael Myers.
So it looks as if a lot of the deaths in this
movie will be callbacks to other moments in
the franchise, despite them not being on this
timeline.
And back to the bathroom stall for a moment,
this drawing on the stall door really stands
out.
To me it looks like a dog wearing sunglasses
looking to the left, but I couldn’t help
but notice if you erase part of it, you’ve
got the Cult of Thorn symbol from Halloween
4, 5, and 6.
Now, do I think the cult will be making an
appearance in this movie?
No, absolutely not.
It would just be a fun easter egg for the
fans of those movies.
Let me know your interpretation of the bathroom
stall drawing in the comments though.
I already found my most *DISLIKED* character.
The lady wearing a Christmas sweater on Halloween.
A lot of people were confused about this scene,
where Laurie shoots because she thinks she
sees Michael in the window of this house.
Some were comparing it to H20, where Laurie
has constant hallucinations of Michael, but
if you slow it down it looks like it’s actually
just a mirror that she sees him through.
One thing that I found creepy is that there’s
actually somebody in the other room over here,
watching this all go down, and the person’s
head immediately snaps toward the room that
Michael is in.
Judging by the lighting, I’d say that room
with the blue light is... this room, where
there is yet another reference; this time
to the ghost scene from the first Halloween,
where Michael wears the ghost sheet over his
head to trick Laurie’s friend Lynda into
thinking he was her boyfriend, Bob, in order
to get her guard down.
I do think that Laurie’s granddaughter is
going to be the main protagonist in this movie,
and it looks like one of her friends is a
babysitter, so don’t be surprised if what
goes down in this movie is very similar to
the events of 40 years ago.
If you enjoyed any of these Things You Missed,
feel free to drop a like on this video.
Let me know if the comments who you think
is crazier.
This Laurie, or the Laurie from the Rob Zombie
Halloween films.
Anyway, if you’re new here, I’m CZ.
I write and narrate my own horror stories
as well.
I just came out with one called Creepy Clown
School Lockdown 2.
Don’t worry, you don’t need to see the
first one, so go ahead and give it a listen.
OK, last announcement, if you’re going to
VidCon come to my fan meetup on Thursday the
21st at 5:30PM in Room 211.
We’re going to raffle off some merch and
there will be other cool creators there as
well.
OK, with that all out of the way, I think
we’re gonna be talking a lot about this
Halloween movie so make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.